this is an ad from Gillette in the 1980s
and note the positive role models and
the sort of pleasantness that we could
do in a nationwide ad in the 80s
you're looking sharp you're looking good
[Music]
where the race is wrong
to let Contour plus with lubricating
strip the best a man can get
the point is that we used to have a
culture I mean think about a Gillette
right and I'm sure Gillette was owned by
it and probably still is now owned by a
massive Corporation Beyond Gillette just
Gillette
um and they put money in advertising to
show people to be proud to show people
you can accomplish things uh you can
build a family you can find someone that
loves you you can have kids it's so
counter to what is being pushed on us
all the time now
I'd like to juxtapose you know I like
the word juxtapose I'd like to juxtapose
that with an ad from Gillette in 2019. a
mere four years ago and you tell me
is the message of Gillette in the 80s or
is the message of Gillette in 2019 a
better more positive message take a look
bullying the metoo movement against
sexual harassment masculinity
is this the best a man can get
is it
a problem
harassment is taking over it's been
going on far too long
[Applause]
we can't laugh at all
what I actually think she's trying to
say making the same old excuses boys
will be boys will be boys but something
finally changed
regarding sexual assault
sexual harassments
and there will be no going back
because we
we believe in the best in men men need
to hold other men accountable smile
sweetie come on
to say the right thing
to act the right way not cool not cool
some already are
and weighs big foreign
[Music]
but some is not enough
we treat each other okay okay
because the boys watching today foreign
[Music]